in 1981 the president of the united
states ronald reagan
was shot by a gunman in washington dc it
wasn't fatal
but it was close reagan was rushed to
hospital and in the chaos
the biscuit went missing the biscuit was
the nickname given to a small plastic
card
sealed inside an opaque case that
contained the secret codes that would
identify the president over the phone
if he gave the instruction to fire a
nuclear weapon
the card was eventually found some
reports say that had been hastily
stuffed in the president's shoe when the
trauma
team cut away his clothes others say
that the fbi had seized all of those
clothes and the card as evidence and
they didn't give it back until a couple
of days later it's possible that both
are true
depending on the timing now there are
some over-excited people who will say
that for however long that card was
missing it would have been impossible
for the united states to launch
or to reply to a nuclear exchange
that's not true the vice president had a
backup but in 1981 in the middle of the
cold war
a president with lost nuclear codes
added some
instability that the world really didn't
need
this story has something to do with your
phone i promise
there are three ways that a computer or
any system can
identify you it can ask for something
you know something you are
or something you have those are the
three factors
of authentication and the gold standard
for checking identity
is multi-factor authentication at least
two
of those different factors two different
passwords aren't much better than one
but two factors are when you do
something as simple as withdrawing cash
from an atm
that is two-factor authentication the
something you have is your card
and the something you know is your pin
so let's look at each of these factors
first something you know well for that
these days that's
a password the traditional login system
username and password is usually
credited
to dr fernando corbeto at mit in the
1960s
and when the only input device to your
computer
is a keyboard a password absolutely
makes sense
something you know could also be a pin
which is just a short password
or in the days before computers your
signature but using this one
factor isn't ideal signatures can be
forged
passwords can be leaked or intercepted
either by someone hacking into the
server they're stored on
or putting a key logger on your computer
or just by someone looking over your
shoulder while you type
i actually taught myself to shoulder
surf passwords when i was in high school
learned a teacher's password got in
trouble for it and
the only reason that i got caught the
only reason
is because i told someone else that i'd
done it i i didn't even want to do
anything with the password i was just a
sort of nerd who taught himself skills
like that for fun
because i could and the lesson i learned
was not don't do it
it was keep your mouth shut anyway
passwords
not ideal but reasonable in the absence
of
any other options what about the next
factor
something you are well that would be
biometrics things like fingerprint and
face recognition
those are great for proving who a person
is and they are difficult to intercept
although they do have downsides the
system has to trust that the device
that's reading the print or checking the
face
hasn't been compromised and if your
fingerprint gets leaked because
some high-tech spy took a copy of it
from a glass that you drank from
you can't exactly change it i tried once
plus you can pretend not to know a
password it doesn't work for your own
face
some people do say that there is a
fourth factor of authentication
somewhere you are the idea that if your
credit card transactions suddenly move
to the other side of the globe
it might be worth checking what's going
on but i'd say that gets rolled into
something you are science fiction
writers have
also imagined complicated artificial
intelligence systems that
can learn someone's behavior patterns
over time and recognize them
or panopticon societies where privacy is
a thing of the past and
everyone knows where everyone is and
what they're doing all the time but
right now for something you are we're
basically stuck with fingerprints and
faces
so how about the third factor something
you have
that would be your bank card or your
phone
or a literal key which is ideal if you
are in the same
physical location if you are unlocking a
door but how do you prove
that someone has a physical object when
they're in a completely
different location well that was a lot
more difficult before smartphones
british banks have been sending out card
readers to their customers for
many years you plug in your card it
reads a secret code off the chip
and then you type in your pin and a
one-time code that your bank sends you
for each transaction
and it mashes all those together does a
lot of maths and the result
is a number that you send back to your
bank confirming that you have the
physical card
but these days often you don't need all
that fuss because almost everyone
carries a phone now and that's a
physical thing that can work as a token
just by
sending a notification to an app on it
that's often secure enough
sometimes that is still done with
numbers and text messages but
that's not ideal sms is not secure and
there have been attacks where criminals
have called up phone providers
and convinced the provider to move
someone's number over to another phone
that the criminal controls or you can
use an authenticator app on your phone
now that generates one-time codes when
you set up the app it stores a long
secret code from the server then it
combines that with the current time and
every minute you get a different six
digit number that you can type in
to prove that you have that phone it's
basically a password that your
phone knows but you don't and the codes
you type in can be short because they
only last a minute each
of course if you're not actually talking
to your bank you're talking to
some phishing website that's just taking
the number you give them and passing it
on to the bank pretending to be you
well that's not ideal so some really
high security companies use a small
physical usb or bluetooth token instead
google
gave those out to all their employees
and they claim it reduced the number of
successful phishing attacks to
zero the actual process of how it works
is way way way beyond the scope of this
video but it's basically equivalent to
the bank card reader only automatic and
with
a lot more complicated maths going on
behind the scenes to make sure
that the key will only talk directly to
the correct web server
and because there's nothing for you to
type in you can't accidentally give the
code to someone else you are required
to have the actual physical token
those us nuclear codes use all three
factors of authentication something you
have the biscuit the actual code card
something you know well there were fake
codes printed on that card so
the president had to memorize the
position of the correct one so when he
cracked open the card
hopefully he'd never have to but when he
cracked open the card he'd know which
one to read out
and something you are he had to be
surrounded by the security apparatus and
top secret infrastructure that would let
him make the call to the military in the
first place
of course all that multi-factor
authentication could only check
that it really was the president giving
the order that the identity was correct
there was no way to check that the
president was sane or that he wasn't
being coerced
or tricked and in the same way you can
have all the multi-factor authentication
you want on your bank account and on
your email and you should
you should turn that on you should go to
your email provider and your bank and
turn on two-factor authentication for
all your important accounts but it won't
help
if the company that you're sending money
to has been hacked and the payment
details that they've emailed you
actually come from a scammer it won't
stop you falling for a confidence trick
or a multi-level marketing scheme
computers can only do what you say they
can't do what you mean
and they can't stop you from asking for
terrible things
but at least they can be reasonably sure
that it's you
asking
you